you know it's one of the craziest
campaigns I ever seen in American
politics is when millionaires like aocc
Robert Reich Bernie Sanders Elizabeth
War get up and they say tax the rich
constantly but when we show data which
I'm going to show you right now you're
going to be blown away by this you ready
the top 1% the rich the people that have
all these exotic cars and houses you
know they make 22% of all the income in
America but you know what percentage of
all the taxes they pay 42% by the way
you know the bottom 50% you know what
percentage of the income they make in
America today 10.2% but do you know how
much of the taxes that the government
collects they pay 2.3% so who's getting
shafted I got a bunch of data to show
you on what's going on with taxes and
some tells me this is not going to be a
video that AOC Elizabeth Warren Bernie
Sanders or the great the phenomenal
Robert Reich are going to want to see so
if you get value out of this video give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let's get right into we got a
bunch of data to show you here's one of
them the top 1% share of income taxes
has increased overtime so if you look at
this chart you will notice the top 1% is
that dark blue all the way at the top
notice from 2001 they were less than 35%
around 33% and today they're at 43% so
their taxes keep going higher and higher
and higher meanwhile the bottom 50% all
the way at the bottom the red taxes keep
getting lower and lower and lower and
even if you look at the green which is
the between 25 and 50% take a look at 01
they were around 13 14% take a look at
where they're at today around 8% it
keeps getting lower so the reality what
they tell you from stage the rich keep
paying more taxes and middle and poor
keep paying lower taxes Based on data
not based on some speech I'm giving to
gain some votes now having said that you
know AOC a lot of these guys love to
come back and say well in the 50s you
know what about the fact that we had our
highest tax rate in America around 91
94% we got to get back to that because
that's what we got every's like oh my
God maybe did we really do people paid n
how did they pay 91% isn't this the era
when you know Ronald Reagan wouldn't
take two or three movies because above
it he would have to pay certain amount
of taxes let's look at data this is what
the number tells you statista taxing the
rich how America's marginal tax rate has
evolved when you look at this all you
notice is World War II ends and at that
time the top marginal tax rate was 94%
then Reagan brings it to roughly 69.3%
and a lot of people say we should go
back to 94% but let's take a look at the
people imagine no one's going to be more
qualified to investigate what is the
actual taxes the actual effective tax
rate the top 1% paid in America except
from these people that wanted to do the
green new deal with AOC the $30 trillion
Green New Deal that they thought was a
fantastic idea and the way we can do
this by taxing the rich look at what
studies they found after doing the
research here's some data for you this
shows taxes on the rich were not much
higher in the 50s notice the light blue
Mark right there the bar that's the '
50s guess what even though they claimed
94% 91% nobody paid it there was so many
ways people were going to still only pay
40 43 44 45% at that time so when these
guys scream out the top of their lungs
they're able to convince millions of
people cuz most people don't go out
there and do the research but when you
do you're like wait a minute why is she
lying to us nobody paid that anyway but
it's a way to scare the crap out of
billionaires and it's a way to get the
poor to say yes let's punish the rich
Let's punish the job creators these are
very bad people and evil people in
reality you punish them you know who the
hell's going to create jobs who AOC you
think AOC is going to create jobs you
think Elizabeth Warren's going to you
think they would go start a business you
know how hard it is to start a business
you think they're going to do that or
they would much TR to get up there and
talk trash about the people who are
actually willing to do the labor of
risking their savings risking all
everything they have to build a business
to create jobs for others they don't
want to do that they want to go out
there and just talk the they want
you to do the work not them but they'll
manipulate millions of people into
believing how Noble they are and by the
way you know how we talked about this
year 45% 44% remember keep in mind this
is the top 1% of us households this is
the top 1% households right but what did
these 94% of people pay on their income
taxes according to taxfoundation.org
when looking at income taxes
specifically the top 1% of taxpayers
paid an average effective rate of only
16.9% in income taxes during the 50s
16.9% not 94% the effective tax rate was
16.9 Allin households based on the
following names say zuckman all
these names together who were part of
the green New Deal after they're doing
this research they're like oh we
should have never done this I'm glad
they did because they realize it's not
as easy as getting up there saying let's
tax the rich 94% which in reality was
only 16.9% so when you think about tax
rat there's a couple things you got to
know there's two different costs one is
the statut
tax rate the other one is the effective
tax rate for example you know how you
hear this is the interest rate well not
necessarily it's not the real interest
rate because the real interest rate is
what you first take interest rates that
we have minus inflation equals real
interest rates the same applies when you
want to find out the difference between
the statutory tax rate and the effective
tax rate you have to consider both
statutory tax rate is the rate imposed
by law on taxable income that falls
within a given tax bracket the effect
Ive tax rate is the percentage of income
actually paid by an individual or a
company after taking into account tax
breaks including loopholes deductions
exemptions credits and preferential
rates which by the way this is a the the
magical moment between Trump and Hillary
Clinton where she says you know all the
money and the tax loopholes and he
hasn't paid any taxes and all this other
stuff and then Trump says I'm sorry
you've been here for 30 something years
and how come those Loop loopholes are
still there he says all your donors take
advant manage the same loopholes I'm
taking why is it if you care so much
about Middle America you haven't done
anything about it for 35 years why
because that's what they do they get up
and they talk and they know 80% of
America is not going to go study it and
look at this kind of stuff and they're
just going to vote and say wow she
doesn't like rich people most of her
money is coming from rich people but she
gives them loopholes that don't worry
you ain't going to pay that kind of
taxes this loophole and that loophole
and this it's going to save you all this
money it's going to be okay but I'm
going to get out there and trash the
rich while taking all the super P money
from you fortunately for many many years
I was naive and I sat there and I said
all these people there until finally I
realized I got to kind of do a little
bit of research to find out for myself
and when you do you realize this is all
a show these are great showmen and
showwoman that able to convince a bunch
of different people and then they
realize this was all fake it was so
again let me go back to 1950s when World
War II they're like we got to figure out
a way to tax the rich people at the same
time here's what came out in 1954 was
called the Internal Revenue Act of 1954
a sweeping overhaul of the IRS that
standardized and expanded the exemptions
deductions and tax shelters established
the 501c3 which is what this is the
nonprofit organizations where you're
able to write off so Ira 1954 dropped 10
points off the effective tax rate of
several of the top tax reporting
instantly effective rates continue to
drift downward as tax planners became
more versed at using these tools hence
you get up there you say let's tax the
rich listen we're going to come out with
this one thing called this don't worry
about it you're not going to pay a lot
of tax cuz you're going to be able to
put it through this it's going to be all
right no problem you got fantastic great
job guys woo let's go now if you're
asking a question the saying well Pat
show us proof like this is going to make
the rich richer come on Pat what what do
you mean by this is going to be that
effective it's going to do such and such
and the money is going to get back into
the market the only way to show it to
you is to show you some charts from Dow
Jones here's Dow Jones take a look at
this that's from 1920 to 1955 go all the
way to the right to 1954 look at between
August of 53 where that was around 270
is and look where it goes to right after
this Internal Revenue Act of 1954 it
skyrockets from 270 to 500 in how long
in 18month is you know what that is
that's almost a rate of return of 80% in
a year and a half how awesome is that do
you see how politics Works they give you
whatever they want on the outside and
you fall forward behind closed doors
don't worry about it you're going to be
able to write this off that's how this
works this next part I'm sure you've
heard of it guess doesn't like this
concept called The laugher Curve the
people that want to tax the rich they
hate this why because they can't argue
common sense and logic so think about it
this way incentive what incentive do you
need for you to give your best so let's
look at taxes if taxes are 100% okay
meaning you make $10,000 a month you're
going to get tax $10,000 okay what's the
incentive to work for what what are you
going to work for now if taxes are zero
you go work and make money the
government maybe doesn't have any money
to go build roads and Military and all
this other stuff so you're kind of like
you know what I kind of want somebody
else to do the cops and firefighters and
all this other stuff I'm willing to give
a little bit perfect Arthur L I've had
him on a couple times figure this number
out to see at what point do we lose
incentive to want to give our best the
number he came up with was roughly a
third you make $50,000 30% $15,000 35
still an incentive you make $100,000 IRS
keeps 30% you don't like it but it's not
to the point where you're not willing to
work you'll still go push I'll never
forget in California when taxes state
and federal all together got to like 56
57% one of these top realtors this woman
never forget we're at this place called
Wood Ranch she was all over the place
all these buses and all these you know
bus stops you saw her face everywhere
she was a celebrity in the valley and I
see her at the Wood Ranch with my wife
and I'm like hey just out of curiosity I
haven't seen your face a lot lately she
says yeah you haven't is say any reason
why not she really want to know she's
sitting with her husband I said yeah of
course I really want to know she said my
husband I one day sat down I was making
$3 $400,000 a year but half of it was
was going to taxes and we just sat there
and said is it even worth me doing this
and we just decided no it's not worth it
so I stopped working and I just stay
home with the kids really yeah wow I
walked away sat down I'm like the high
taxes in California told us later
there's no incentive to want to give
your best so our community lost a
fantastic realtor because of the
incentives were not worth her giving her
best and she said I'm done so now we
always hear about the 1% but we don't
talk about the 0 1% but if we look at
their incomes based on this chart here's
what you'll notice the green is the 1%
notice their income from 1950 till today
where it's at and then look at the pink
which is a top
.01% from 1950 till today the Pink's
average income today give or take is
between 30 to $40 million a year of
annual income but 1% is between a half a
million to million there's a big
difference the top 1% gets taxed more
than any other group The Top .01% pays
less taxes than any other major group
The analysis from omba and CA Economist
estimates that the wealthiest 400
billionaire families in America pay an
average 88.2% of their income why their
income because people don't know how
that works out including income from
their wealth that goes largely on tax in
federal individual income tax between
2010 and 2018 wealthy households can
Finance themselves without paying
capital gain taxes on the occurring
wealth by following a buy borrow Di
strategy they typically Finance current
spending with loans and use their wealth
as collateral so if you break it down
with this chart this says a lot if you
take a look at this here's what you'll
notice sources of income by AGI
percentile the blue represents actual
wages yellow represents investment gray
represents retirement and orange
represents business and other go to 0 to
80% not all returns right below 0 80%
where do most of them rely on their
income it's wages you notice that
roughly 80% right then some it's
retirement some it's investment very
small percentage is what business and
other now go to 1% which is the 98 to 99
not much changes they're still relying
on wages then retirement then is
investment then it's business now go to
0.1% notice what happens with wages gets
lower and lower and lower while
investment gets more and more and more
and business actually decreases because
eventually when you get to this level of
wealth you're no longer operating all
the time businesses you just have so
much money that you're making
investments in different companies and
that keeps getting bigger and bigger and
bigger so as much as it's easy to say
well the 0 1% doesn't pay that much
taxes because they're no longer taking
income the way they do and they have
better tax planning strategies behind
closed doors they use the same codes
that all these politicians claim don't
want the rich to take advantage of you
came up with these policies you the
politician they didn't come up with it
you did you're like well it's just a
favor I did to seven of them because
they give all this money to my super
pack totally get it but that's you you
did that not the American people this is
why many people would say flat tax would
be the fairest thing to do with
everybody get rid of everything and just
create a flat tax but no no no nobody
would do that nobody would do that cuz
then actually people would start having
pay taxes and they're not going to do
that so try to get any politician from
the left right or the middle agree on a
flat tax someone the right would agree
but not the left they're not going to
agree with it and there's a reason why
let me give you some more stats on this
cuz it's pretty interesting 158 million
Americans or 61% of us adults own stocks
not everybody top 1% holds ready
54% of stocks you know what it's worth
take a while guess a trillion trillion
and a half how about $1 19.16 trillion
the top 1% the wealthiest 10% of
American households own 80 9% of all US
Stocks the bottom 90% of Americans own
roughly 11 the bottom 50% of us adults
own only 6% of stocks worth $21 billion
that's bottom 50% I want to show you
some things for last 50 years it's
important for us to take a look at this
if you see this chart here share of us
aggregate income look at the yellow
which represents the middle income
that's 62% in 1970 and now in 2018 it's
43% but if you look at upper income they
used to be only 29% went from 29% to 48%
ahead of middle income and lower income
went from 10% to 9% and if you go to the
bottom share of us aggregate wealth look
what the upper income does keeps getting
higher and higher from 60% to 79 middle
income goes from 32 to 17 lower 7 to a
big part of this is because the lower
and middle income they don't think
long-term they don't invest they don't
put money into 401ks investment stocks
bonds mutual funds you know how I know
this I'm in the Army and I'm getting out
of the army had a friend of mine Jeff
every month he would put $100 $200 we
had no money we're making 800 bucks a
month I'm partying buying alcohol liquor
going to the clubs everything's on me
this guy is always putting $200 a month
into his Roa I'm filled my fridge in my
room was the best tequila come on down
baby I'm stacked with Jose quo he's like
I'll drink your Jose quo but I ain't
buying it if you're offering short
brilliant few years later he's got
$220,000 in a bank you know what I got
in a bank zero baby you know why cuz I
was low middle income thinking oh I'm
not making enough money to save
excuse everybody wants to make if I was
making more money I would save money
here's what I've learned guys I know
people making 5 million a year and
they're broke you know why cuz when they
were making 50k a year they were not
saving that haboc didn't change and I
know people that are making $80,000 a
year and they're millionaires because
they were saving money when they were
only making 20 grand a year this is not
about the richest fault and all this
other stuff you watching this you have
to have a conversation with yourself and
your family saying how much money do I
need to make to start saving money do it
now no more barbecue no more this no
more doubt I'm going to set some money
aside no matter what happens that habit
is going to be passed down to your kids
your family everybody else and then
eventually everybody's going to be doing
well financially but at this point this
ain't looking good for lower and middle
inome families so look if you're
watching this you know whe whether you
agree with me disagree with me I'm
totally fine you can leave your comments
below and I respect it you know I'm
comfortable with that but I will tell
you this there's a lot of different
solutions we can look at and say but Pat
do you not see the fact that they're
using debt to do this this this this
that why can't well that's not fair
again these are laws politicians created
yes if we get rid of the lobbyist a lot
of this wouldn't happen because these
billionaires and millionaires maybe are
buying lobbyist totally fine I'm with
getting rid of lobbyist yes we can sit
there and say well you know I I don't
think this is cool why don't we you know
raise taxes on these guys fine then why
don't we go back to when the tax code
was only six pages back in 1913 small
couple Pages 100,000 pages today let's
rip the whole thing apart let's start
from the beginning let's get rid of all
these loopholes well no no no
it's going to impact some of you by the
way just so you know that as well no
that's not what I'm saying but you know
what happens almost everybody that
starts talking about taxes you know
what's the hardest thing most people can
do to actually have a reasonable
conversation knowing what's going to
benefit the country long term not just
you had a conversation one of my sales
leaders in the new comp I was presenting
to them he kept telling me what about
this and what about I said can you for
one stop only thinking about your own
commission and think about what we need
to do to grow the company to the next
level that is the only thing I'm
interested in I want to know how to grow
the company to the next level and he
like okay okay that's fair that's fair
but what about this I'm like again three
times you brought up three different
issues you didn't think about other guys
all you thought about is yourself if we
can sit there and have a reasonable Fair
conversation to not destroy job creators
to give an opportunity for people to
increase their lifestyle and call out
the BS habits that some people have if
we can put that together then we can
work somewhere and start making some
progress but if you start off with the
first thing thinking about maybe you're
poor you're like we should tax the rich
if you're rich we should then you can't
have a reasonable conversation we're
having this conversation because most of
these politicians get up and start with
their tax the rich concept and they get
the able to manipulate the lower and
middle income families into voting for
them and then the people that are
actually working hard like many of you
who watch this content you pay the price
for it this is why we create content
like this to educate others if you got
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel by the
way and you know what the one thing we
don't teach in school that everybody
should study is taxes now I know taxes
are so boring who the hell wants to
study taxes we should study biology and
mitosis not taxes but guess what
everybody going to school you're going
to be dealing with taxes for the rest of
your life so I made an episode it's one
of the mustat doesn't get a lot of views
but it's something you got to study it's
the history of taxes when you find out
what link did with taxes back in the
1800s I'm going to ask you question in
this video you're going to give the
wrong answer because I give the wrong
answer as well and then you're going to
say what that's what Lincoln did that's
what he did if you never seen that video
click here to watch it take care
everybody bye-bye
[Applause]
bye-bye